[Applause]
I am obsessed with your products and
we're going to get into all those things
in a minute but I have to transition
with
is it true that you went to Italy yes I
spent a year in Italy my junior year of
college and uh I went to an Italian
school over there I used to be floating
Italian it's all gone really yeah did
you bring anything home with you from
Italy his name was Fabio foreign
he didn't know English he was site
specific he worked really well in Italy
but once I brought him back and realized
that he didn't speak any English he was
a little tough he also had a little
problem with the food
and one day he's like clutching his gut
and he said Julie die and he's like in
Italian he's telling me that he's dying
because he ate a whole packet of
prosciutto and marscapone
and I'm like for [__] I was in college I
mean I didn't have to shoot a mascarpone
so I go on and look in the garbage and
there's an empty package of raw bacon
and an empty tub of cream cheese
oh my God that's so that is gonna make
you sick yes he was and all I laughed
and laughed and picked up the phone and
called the Airlines and you're going
home
but she he wasn't gonna make it a
hundred percent because sue a member of
our audience
where is she she's up there in the red
turtleneck Sue and I were talking about
like we we're not sure we want to be in
relationships we're both single ladies
and we're really happy and where do you
stand on this issue I'm I like where I
am I like wearing that oh I'm single
so we've got another
you know working like who has the time
so what do you think about Julie's words
and and thoughts and feelings are you
feeling you know the solidarity of
Sisterhood right now
[Laughter]
I mean like is it is it sex that you're
missing or is it or companionship
companionship I don't need a guy to have
sex
foreign
oh god
um okay what is your stance on pineapple
on pizza
ew
[Laughter]
it's so nasty it's sweet it's a fruit it
doesn't belong on a pizza no you're
gonna eat a citrus fruit with cheese and
is anybody on my side here she is so
it's funny we actually took a poll for
you oh okay because we knew how we were
on polarizing sides of the spectrum and
it is a polarizing issue we pulled our
audience and 63 percent said they like
pineapple
you're Drew
and and when you're Drew like you're so
fun and I bet they knew I bet like your
audience is self-selecting they're like
fun people right not that much fun I'm
just not that much fun oh God trap I
think you're so fun and so talented I
gotta tell you I am freaking out over
your new line I want everyone to see
this I have to tell you it's my new
favorite product I love the way that
you've designed the packaging but I also
love the story behind it that you did
you were it is for girls it's forever
for everybody we designed it for our
boys in mind because we have boys and
nobody is paying attention to them when
they one day they go into the bathroom
and they close the door behind them and
you can't go in there I mean you wash
their underwear you're like it's not
working whatever you're doing there
we've got to step up our game okay and
you actually had a sub name that you
almost named it and it's yes it's on the
packaging it's right here it says Pro JB
scrub tip pits nuts butts
this is why I love you yeah but that's
what you need to I mean fast
[Applause]
[Music]